we've had so many amazing guests over
the years
here's just a tiny sample
of some of the fun we've had december 8
2007 did conan o'brien show went well
i was very hot audience was good conan
seems sluggish
january 6 2008 did conan o'brien very
hot show had some great ad-libs
uh conan seems sluggish
did his dog die
june 15 2009 had dinner with conan
always loved spending time with him
to practice fake laughing
i would love to do this show way more
often but you know pride
you look fantastic thank you marty thank
you you look like a ginger crash test
dummy look at that
[Applause]
how long were you on the embalming table
before you jumped out okay
one of the pieces of memorabilia in my
collection in fact the flagship piece
is a lego millennium falcon that i put
together in 2010
would really mean the world to me if
harrison could sign it is that okay
harrison oh
sure thank you guys so much thank you
wow now it's a very delicate long time
[Music]
yeah
i wrote you every day for a year
you wrote me yes
you it wasn't over
it still isn't
played this brilliant game called
tequila slaps okay so you take the shot
okay and how much time do i get just go
not much time
you made the cover of men's health in
the uk
which and it's a very look at that build
arms like this
oh fantastic
are you okay betty i'm getting better
what would the price be for i've never
really thought about
the value of these things and some i
just found out about this sword going
for 100 000
which is crazy i mean there are i think
maybe 10 of these
in existence so right it would have to
be comparable
i actually work with dogs we actually
actually train dogs they'll go one at a
time they'll go up the uh
the ladder here then through the uh the
uh the weeds
uh through the tunnel and the chute
across the tightrope and then up
the uh teeter-totter and down the other
side okay
good okay okay
send you up sit sit up
no no no no no pepino
[Music]
hey hey you get back here okay i'm gonna
ship you off to a mexican circus
you get over here and you do you do the
thing that we worked on
okay you go through you go through here
through
through through through
stop laughing they can't concentrate
they can't concentrate because you
idiots aren't they giving that respect
you think this is easy for them they're
scared of us okay
please welcome zach galifianakis
zach galifianakis
[Applause]
[Music]
zach galifianakis
zach galifianakis
[Applause]
you also do an impression of a turtle
single single person oh my gosh what do
you talk about oh
single all i want is a big dick
[Applause]
my mother used to say it takes more to
frown than it does to smile
so i can be like [ __ ] you with a smile
on my face
you know i probably shouldn't point out
every question
i asked you go down a certain
i could ask you you know what's your
favorite thing about a rainbow you know
and you'll be like oh the [ __ ] color
i thought you were gonna go get to the
end of it there's a
[Applause]
hey this is great yeah
please welcome andy sandberg and his new
baby girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
put your lips together and put your
tongue out just a tiny bit
[Music]
[Applause]
this hand let me go let me get this hand
i'm watching can you have this hand
now they all know the conan that we know
do you want me conan yes yes you have to
act like you want me i want you
i want you i want to okay i want you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Applause]
it's not the singing it's the face he
makes
that's my orgasm face
[Applause]
do you want to see mine you want to see
more yeah oh yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
you